C-Tiers? There's a whole conversation that was happening in the Discord that's like,
okay, well, you need a better name for us than C-T-E-R-S. C-Tiers. Yeah. We're all from Connecticut.
Yeah. We're all like C-Tier hackers. We're all C-Tier hackers. Yeah.
Hey guys, real quick. I just wanted to tell you about our sponsor ThreatLocker. Now, wait,
wait, before you hit the skip forward button, let me just say this. Most of the stuff that holds my
attention nowadays is Red Team stuff as well. But I sat down with the ThreatLocker team this past week
to do a demo of their EDR software. And it was super technically fascinating how this thing works.
So check this out. You drop this thing on a system, right? And for the first week or so,
it's creating a policy and a profile for that system. It's logging all the executables,
what child processes are being spawned, the files and their hashes, that sort of thing.
And it's creating this policy. Okay. Then after the learning mode is up, we're in secured mode,
and that policy gets put into place. And anything that's not on that allow list is immediately auto
denied. That's the zero trust piece, right? So in addition to that, they've got a bunch of crazy
features like ring fencing and dynamic access controls that would stop a malicious hacker at
pretty much every step along the way. Actually, I was watching this demo and I was kind of freaked
out because I have no idea how I would cope with getting dropped into a ThreatLocker system
as a Red Teamer. Anyway, if you want to learn more about this, head over to ThreatLocker.com
and request a demo. And when you do, ask for my boy, Andrew. His demo was super to the point,
and he was able to answer all my technical questions. All right, cool. Back to the show.
You hear that, Joel? You hear that? That's a brainstorm coming. That is the rain.
Bro.
Ah, wow. That was... Are you going to keep that?
Dude, Justin hyped this up. He's like, dude, I got the best intro. Wait till you hear this.
Oh my gosh. Wait till you hear this. Okay.
You know, but it's like I made the voice, you know, I did the sound with my mouth, you know,
for the brain, when it's raining, you know, and then it's a brainstorm. You see what I'm saying?
I thought we were talking about toilets again in the beginning.
No, no, no, no. We're not doing it. We're not doing it.
Ah, all right, dude. Ready for a brainstorm episode?
Uh, I guess so. Yeah. Dude, I, um, I was, uh, did you have thunderstorms yesterday?
Because we had, we had thunderstorms. I thought that's why you, you brought that up.
No, no. My house is not leaking. Everything is good. I just, you know, the amount of
valuable information that is just raining out of our brains right now.
Raining. It just needed to be vocalized.
Yes.
All right. Well, thanks for bearing with me there, Joel, for that. Um, so we're going to
brainstorm today on, um, various types of plugins, extensions, Chrome extensions,
Kaido extensions, Burp extensions, Men in the Middle proxy extensions, all these sort of things.
Um, but before we get to that, man, Gareth Hayes just tweeted something out, dude. And you know,
when Gareth Hayes tweets something out, your boy is on it. Like here on a gorilla.
Yes. So I, he's one of the few people who I've tweet notifications turned on for.
Yeah.
Uh, along with the critical thinking podcast.
Critical, critical, critical.
Oh man.
Anyways.
We've been getting a little goofy lately.
This is not good, dude.
We gotta bring this in.
All right.
Uh, okay.
But anyways, I like went and I sat down on the toilet and I pulled my phone out and sure
enough, I have all these tweet notifications from Gareth Hayes and, uh, he's tweeted some
crazy big brain.
Uh, I don't even know.
What is this?
A zero day.
Weird behavior.
So, okay.
So let me, let me clarify on this because I saw this and I was like, wait, what the heck?
This is super weird.
I hadn't even understood this.
And, and then like, John Carlson pops in there and he's like, eh, this is like kind of cool,
but pretty normal.
But let me add some context to this.
Okay.
So, um, the tweet that Gareth tweeted out that we're talking about is essentially just
an a tag that he tweeted out.
And the a tags H ref is a slash and then ampersand B soul, uh, semi-colon, right?
So it's a HTML entity B soul, which apparently is for backslash.
I don't know why it's B soul.
Um, and then he uses like a, like a negative medium space, um, uh, entity as well, HTML entity.
And then, uh, you know, provides shazer.co.uk as the domain where this, uh, H ref should be
going to.
And when you click on this link, it goes to shazer.
Um, and it doesn't start with slash slash.
Um, and, and so like, here's the thing with this is like, there's always so many times we've
talked about it time and time again on the pod where you're trying to fuzz for a way to get around,
a redirect URI or something like that in an OAuth flow, or, um, get this some, some like iframe,
a source attribute to like point to a different host rather than a relative URL within the host.
Right.
Um, and I think this is just another great way to get around it.
And somehow I just hadn't fully formulated in my brain that we can use HTML entities inside of,
uh, these HTML attributes like this.
And especially, you know, with the research that came out from the RCE man that we covered on the pod
a long time ago, um, about, uh, like the different types of HTML entities that have kind of been
overlooked and, and shazer, um, you know, whipped up a whole list of all these crazy HTML entities
that we hadn't heard of before.
Um, this is just becoming more important in my brain is like, okay, how can we utilize these sort of
under, underserved, under known HTML entities to break out of these various contexts, um, inside of
an HTML attribute.
Um, and I think that's exactly what, what he does here.
Yeah.
Yeah, for sure.
Um, I just posted, uh, a link in the doc.
We will include it in the, in the references, but, uh, Wikipedia actually has a really good table.
Uh, I found that has like just a list of all the XML and HTML, um, character entities.
Jeez.
There's a ton, dude.
I did not know this.
Yeah, there's a ton.
There's a ton, um, of like really weird ones, including like, you know, special characters
and all sorts of stuff like soul and back soul, be soul.
Like you, uh, like you said, um, there's also like fraction slash.
So maybe like our F R A S L. So maybe that would get, um, normalized somewhere somehow.
Um, yeah.
So there's, there's a lot of really interesting, um, interesting stuff.
Yeah.
That fraction slash is a, is not, um, Unicode code point zero zero two F that's Unicode code
code point two zero four four.
So that's like a, like a, a non-ascii, uh, character there.
Um, so man, there's a lot of really interesting stuff here.
I, I think, man, there's just so many, dude, I'm like scrolling and scrolling and scrolling
on how many entities there are here.
And I'm sure there's going to be a bunch of other bugs relating to this, but I,
the, the attack vector that came to my mind and came to the mind of, um, uh,
Hakupiku in the reverse order there.
Right.
And he like, when I saw it, I was like, oh man, this is going to be really helpful in
ReaderX and then like, uh, 10 minutes later, uh, Hakupiku, uh, messages me and he's like,
Hey man, this is really helpful in OAuth flows.
Um, because what you can do is you can set the response type to form post.
Right.
And the way that that works is then it'll generate an HTML element.
So if you have an OAuth flow, that's going to, um, uh, return a code or whatever, like normal
OAuth does, if you set the response type to form post, instead of like 302ing, what it'll do is
generate a HTML page with a, with a form.
And it's going to set the action on that form to be whatever your redirect URL is.
So if you're able to specify a relative URL, you know, and they're saying, all right,
as long as it starts with slash and it doesn't, you know, have a backslash or a forward slash next to it,
um, then we're fine.
And then you can use this sort of entity, this, uh, ampersand B sole, semi-colon, um,
to bypass that flow and actually redirect to an absolute URL, or I guess more specifically,
a protocol relative URL, um, and then leak that code out to, uh, uh, another domain that
isn't within that redirect URI flow.
So my, my prediction, and I think, uh, Haku Piku's, or, um, prediction as well, is that
this will affect a lot of, uh, OAuth flows, uh, specifically in the, the form post environment.
Yeah.
This is really interesting and, uh, I don't want to spoil too much, but I have a,
I have a thought that I see has already been thought ahead of my thought.
So, um, about something related to this, uh, what is, what is your, you're just not going to say
it on the plot?
Well, it's an extension idea.
Oh, really?
Okay.
There you go.
All right.
It's something that's in the list too.
It's already in the list.
It is in the list.
I did put that in the list.
I was like, this would be a good idea.
And then I went and I looked and I was like, this is already a thing.
So yeah.
Um, well, we'll talk about it later, but.
Okay.
Yeah.
No, that sounds, that sounds great.
Um, very cool stuff there.
TLDR of that whole situation.
There's a bunch of weird, weird HTML attributes out or HTML entities out there.
You should know them and definitely check out, check out the, um, the Shazer results for all
the fuzzing of HTML entities that, that Kara's been doing because lots of weird stuff is coming
out of that.
Um, all right.
What's this next one on the list, Joel?
There's a, there's a, there's a link on the list from, from Joel.
From me, from me, this is revolutionary.
Okay.
So, um, Chris Evans, who, uh, is the, uh, the CISO, um, over at hacker one tweeted out that they are
making a change to the hacker one leaderboard.
And now hacker one leaderboards are separated based on bug bounty program reputation,
vulnerability disclosure program reputation, and then both together.
And by default, it shows just the bug bounty program reputation in the leaderboard.
So now VDPs, uh, you're, if you're farming on VDPs, that's not going to boost you in the default
leaderboard.
It will boost you in the separate and combined leaderboards for VDPs and both, but the default
leaderboard is the bug bounty program leaderboard.
That's where you're going to have the most reputation.
I like, I like that they broke it out.
And then I liked that they made a bug bounty program, the default.
And I wonder how this is going to show up on your profile as well, because I think, you know,
the hacker one leaderboards is great for essentially us people, us folks that are really in the hacker
one environment.
And we would like go there and we want to compete and want to see where we're at and
that sort of thing.
But I think for a lot of people, um, the profile is the bigger measure, like being able to have,
you know, hacker one.com slash Ryan reader, you go there, you see, oh, Justin's, you know,
I don't know this month.
I'm probably like not even in the top, uh, hundred or whatever, because I've been doing so much
things for the critical thinkers.
Um, uh, but you know, like that view that's in the, on the profile, I think it's going to be
super duper important, like what is being highlighted there and what metrics says, okay,
in the last 90 days, Justin is, uh, you know, in the top 50 or whatever, as far as a bug bounty
reputation goes.
Yeah.
And I think I may have said that it already is that they already made the change.
It's planned.
I don't know when it's planning on being rolled out.
This was just tweeted, um, less than 24 hours ago yesterday.
Okay.
So yeah, it's, uh, it's still, I don't know, but there's a screenshot, so they're definitely
like engineering it to some extent.
It's probably going to come out within the next couple of weeks.
So, um, pretty soon.
Well, this is, you know, this is the result of that whole conversation that started
a while back, uh, with Noggle, I think tweeting something out and starting a fire like he always does.
Um, and yeah, so it's good to see that them, them actually following through on this and then,
and then, uh, it also just shows like how long it takes to get like a markup of, uh, of what this
UI change should look like in these bigger organizations sometimes, man.
And, uh, you know, that's the world of, uh, software engineering.
I, I always think things should take less long than they do, but it is what it is.
Yeah.
You never know.
It's always, it's always impossible to plan these things properly.
Yeah, for sure.
Alrighty, man.
Cool.
Well, let's get into the storm.
Let the lightning, let the lightning, let the thunder begin.
It's cracking.
Yeah, exactly.
Let's start, let's start brainstorming.
Okay.
So I'll start out with a couple and then you like intro, intro Joel style.
We can, you know, you can just take those ideas and make them better and bounce off of it.
Okay.
Sure.
So, um, first, first one that I wanted to talk about, uh, is I think that
a 403 bypassing workflow in Kaido is something that I really want to want to work on.
And here, and obviously I know that, that there's a, um, that there's a 403 bypasser plugin in Burp
Suite.
Okay.
Um, and if you look at that plugin, it does, you know, it shows all these like path traversal things
that it will do.
And it tries, it lists like maybe eight things that it will try in there.
And, um, here's the problem with that is I feel like this needs to be custom for each person.
Because I know there's a ton of tricks that I know that are not in this, uh, 403 bypasser
extension.
Right.
And if I have this 403 bypasser extension, I'm going to see a 403 and I'm going to right click on
it.
I'm going to say trigger the, the 403 bypasser extension, and then it's going to do its thing.
And then I'm going to assume that it tried the things and it's not.
So this is one of the things that I really like about, about Kaido is like, um, for one,
there's a lot of ground that Kaido has to make up, uh, on the, on the plugin space and we're moving
towards it.
We're, we're, we're knocking it out.
Um, it'll be there probably within the next year or so.
But, um, I think that one of the areas where it shines is this whole concept of custom automation.
Right.
Not everybody has the time to go break out their Java environment and build their own
custom burp plugins that are like super hard to write in your using this language.
And it's just, uh, whereas with Kaido, you've got the, the low code, no code interface for automation.
You can easily say, okay, Hey, I want to take the request.
I want to sub, uh, I want to do URL encoding on the last, uh, portion of the, of the path.
Right.
And I want to resend that request and I want an alert if that response is different than
the response that I send without URL encoding that.
Right.
This is classic 403 bypass or bypassing technique.
So I think there's a lot of merit to having your own 403 bypassing methodology automated and
implemented in a workflow, or if you, you are a diehard burp fan in your own burp extension.
Um, because those things that you know about how to bypass 403s or that you have experience with
about how to get around a certain control, that's what makes you unique as a hacker.
And that's what you need to automate.
Yeah.
Yeah, for sure.
I, yeah, I think, um, generally speaking, there's a lot of plugins that need to be ported
over and we're, there's a couple that we're gonna talk about specifically.
Yeah.
Um, so that are like really great plugins that should be ported over.
Um, and I think probably some of them might be able to be made work a lot easier.
Mm-hmm.
Like Kaido, you can call shell commands.
So if you really want, it's written in Python, which a lot of them are for, to work with Jython,
like you could just take the core functionality of that plugin, put it in a separate Python file,
call it out directly from Kaido in a workflow and just, you know, call it a day.
Don't bother making it more complicated than that.
Um, but I think some are definitely a little more complicated than that and a lot more involved
or they have UI components and stuff like that, that need to be converted over.
Um, but once those things can be ported over, it's going to be huge.
Yeah.
And I, I don't know that I mentioned this to you, but there's a, probably by the time this
episode airs, um, the basic implementation of backend plugins for Kaido will be in place,
which will open up the possibilities for creating things like Autorize and, um, uh, like, um,
Turbo Intruder and, and all these sort of, uh, like a single packet attack based thing,
right. Um, all of these sort of key features of, of burp, um, will be able to be ported over here
shortly. And I'm really looking forward to that. And I think that's, that's great. And I think it
also creates an opportunity for us to look at these plugins that we've been trusting for years and
years and years and say, okay, I've used this tool time and time again, where are my pain points?
And, and let me make this better when I transition it over to Kaido, you know, or, or when I transitioned
it over to like a, a men in the middle proxy extension, like we were talking about where
if you want to write something that is independent of Kaido or independent of burp, right. Then maybe
men in the middle proxy might be the right solution, or you can just kind of chain these things together.
And it's a very lightweight intermediate that doesn't cost anything. Um, so yeah, I think there's a lot of,
a lot of ground to cover up there, but I think, I think we're moving towards it. And I really think that
whole concept of it customized automation to the hacker, um, will become, will become huge.
Yeah. Yeah, for sure. Um, on that topic, another one that I would love to see is like hackverter
type behavior for Kaido. Um, yeah, dude. Okay. So that actually is going to be native and introduced
like next week. So definitely by the time this episode airs, um, that will be, that will be
released and essentially how it's going to work is, um, there's going to be, you know, there's this
whole concept of convert workflows in Kaido, right? You select some range of bytes or whatever, right.
And it pipes it into a workflow where you can do all sorts of stuff, manipulate it, encode it, decode it,
run a run JavaScript on it, you know, all that sort of thing. And then essentially that is going to be
integrated right into the replay tab, which is the Kaido equivalent of repeater in, um, in Kaido.
Um, and so essentially like we use, uh, you know, how like an intruder and an automate,
you like select a little region where you're going to start brute forcing.
Yeah. So yeah. With those little like marker things.
Yeah. With the little marker things. So we're going to have the same thing like that in Kaido
where, and it's already built, it's just hasn't been released yet where, um, you select a certain
portion and you select a convert workflow that goes along with it. And then when you send that request,
it will automatically dump it through that convert workflow, which is going to be absolutely massive
for, um, doing some more complicated testing in an environment where like, all right, now I've got
to like take it and URL encode it, then base 64 encode it, then URL encode the base 64, you know,
like, and then convert all of the slashes to dashes and like that sort of thing.
Yeah. I do love how modular the, the like convert workflow, like ideology is, um, cause you can call
other convert workflows from convert workflows.
Yeah. I mean, you can chain them. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
So that'll be, but I think the whole, the whole concept is, you know, around the, the workflows is
you have these little nodes where you can do each individualized pieces, um, along the way in one
convert workflow. Right. Yeah. Yeah. And they function kind of as extensions in the same way
as well. Yeah. And so you can write like encapsulated JavaScript in one and then pass it to another
one and that sort of thing. Right. Yeah.
Super cool. Super cool.
Yeah. Hackverter will be great. All right. So let me, let me tell you about this one, man. And actually,
this one's already implemented and this one is already released to the critical thinkers, um,
and the discord, which by the, by the way, there have been like 30 plus people that have joined
the critical thinkers tier over the past like week.
So they, this book, this book he wrote is a killer. It's, it's, it's, it's flying off the shelves.
Best seller in the, in the bug bounty world. Um, no, the New York times
top read his digest.
100 copies sold.
No, uh, I really do appreciate that. All of you that have subscribed over the past, uh, week. Uh,
it's amazing to see so encouraging and thank you for all the positive feedback about the, uh,
the full-time bug bounty blueprint that's been amazing. Um, so yeah, shout out, shout out to y'all.
But anyway, the, the extension that I was going to talk about has already been released to, um,
the critical thinkers, uh, and essentially it's, so have you ever heard of, um, what is the name of it?
It's like a spin, a spando. What is the spando? Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
! Yeah.
Have you ever heard of it? Wait, is that the one where you like type something and it converts like
what you wrote into?
Yes.
It's like a tool. It looks like a piece of software you install, right?
It's like a text expander, right? So I use this all the time and all of my stuff is in here.
It's amazing.
And so you showed me this and I think you're crazy for using it by the way, but, but I love you for it.
It's just, I don't know. It's very like, um, it's very like old school. You know what I mean?
Yeah. Like I, I'm, I mean, I, obviously I think we all use it in like our own way. Like I use bash aliases.
Like it's, you know, that's like whatever, but this is like,
Hey, Mr. Calling me, calling me old school.
Listen, listen, I use, I use auto correct for this. Okay. So he's old school. I don't,
I don't use any third party software. I, I, I create like an auto correct, like dictionary entry and
I'll put like my own custom, like H2, I use like HTML encoding format. So I'll use like,
and then like a keyword and then semi-colon, and then I'll type that and auto correct.
You'll be like, did you mean this?
And you're like, yes, I did. Well, all right. Let me explain to the people who don't even know
what this is. So Espanso is a text expander. So essentially I type, um, uh, I type colon wh one.
Right. And that automatically replaces that colon wh one with rhino raider at we are hacker one.
Right. So whenever I'm trying to like log into my, my accounts for testing and stuff like that,
I just type colon wh one and it just populates my, my name. Yeah.
Here's a weird question. Yeah.
Does it work on Android emulators? Like through, like if you're typing,
it happens at the, at the keyboard level. Um, so I think it does.
Does it like backspace?
So like, yeah.
Yeah. Okay.
Which is pretty cool.
That might work.
Yeah.
Cause normally what I have to do is like, I copy something on my clipboard and then I
switch tabs like into the window and it transfers the clipboard over and then it's like kind of
clunky, but it works.
Yeah, it works.
And that's actually, and that's actually how I implement it. So anyway, I took this concept
and I was like, wow, this is great. Um, I want something like this for my HTTP proxy.
Right. Cause I'm constantly going through and I'm like, okay, I've got like Joel's organization ID.
And then Joel's like account ID. And then, you know, and then I'm Justin's account ID,
Joel, you know, Justin's organization ID. And you've got all of these IDs and all of these like
payloads and stuff like that you got to keep track of. And so what you do is, is I built a plugin where you
just essentially hit it, highlight some text, hit a keyboard binding and give it a name. And now,
uh, you can access that, that text that was selected, uh, in the replay tab in any, any interface in Kaido
by just typing like squiggly line and then the name you gave it. And it automatically backspaces the stuff
you wrote and then inserts the, the stuff that you, you had selected in the beginning.
Does it use it, uh, a spando for this, or is this like a fully within Kaido?
This is native to Kaido. I just wrote it in JavaScript and it was really easy.
So it's like globally anywhere, or is it just?
What do you, yeah, anywhere, anywhere inside the Kaido interface, because Kaido's front end is all
JavaScript, right? So, you know, I just wrote a front end plugin that, that just looks for selection
and waits for this key binding. And then when you hit it, it just pops up in alert box. Say,
great. You selected the text, ABC one, two, three. What do you want to name it? And you just type like
a or whatever. And then any type in time you type, uh, whatever that squiggly line is, tilde,
then it backspaces a backspaces tilde and replaces it with ABC one, two, three.
Okay. So you, you got me thinking here because I'm using my brain again. Uh-oh.
Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
Okay. So, um, I used to, so I still do this sometimes when I'm testing a really complex API,
sometimes I will go through the effort of writing it out into like PAW or, um, insomnia or, um,
put a postman or whatever. And I'll, I'll actually structure out the API and I'll build out like parts
of it, especially if it's something that like, for instance, OAuth 2 signing, major pain in the ass
to do testing on. So if you use like a rest client, oftentimes it'll do the signing and it'll update
the header and stuff automatically. Maybe that would be a good kind of plugin in and of itself.
But, um, the point is for like really complex API testing. Um, one of the really nice features I like
about these rest clients is they have like the concept of environments, right? So you have like an
environment with different variables and each of those environments, you can switch between the
environments, you can define variables, and then you can use those variables throughout your project
and you can change them in one place. So like, like you said, like user ID, for example, like
Justin's user ID and Joel's user ID. If I want to do cross account testing, I could create two variables,
like account one ID, account two ID, and then you could just swap that in easily in different parts.
I don't know. Wow.
If you could do that with plugins, but it would be really cool to have some sort of like
environment plugin or variables plugin where you could define different variables,
and then you could use those throughout like in your replay tab, um, or wherever you're trying to
do testing. And then you could change them in one place. You could just have them written down.
Cause I find that a lot of the time when I'm doing testing, especially with cross account testing for
ID or some stuff, I just have to like write it down in my notes and just like put it at the top of
the note and just keep it there. Cause I don't really have a really good way of doing that sort of
testing other than that. Um, and having it defined within the proxy would be really neat.
Yeah, absolutely. And, and, and that solves that whole problem of like, okay, your session died and
now all of your, your repeater tabs or your replay tabs or whatever are, are dead. And now you've got
to like copy the cookie in, you know, 15 bajillion times until, you know, it, until you've repopulated all
of your requests and that sort of thing. Right. Well, and I think it's like one nicer step up from
your expand thing as well, because it, again, like you can update it in one place. So if your account
gets banned and you have to create a new one and you want to change that all of your expanded text,
that's like just like static within the request, but this would like reference like a variable,
so to speak. And then you could just like change it in one place and it would all of them would still
update dynamically. Yeah, no, I like that. I like that a lot. And I think that's something that,
that this exact concept is something we've discussed with the Kaido team of creating this
sort of like global variable of sorts that you can use, you know, and automate and replay and that
sort of thing. And I would love to see Burp implement something like this too, because at the end of the
day, something like this should absolutely exist already. And it's kind of odd that it, that it doesn't.
And it should be pretty easy to do. I know that with, you know, with these convert workflows in Kaido,
you could sort of hack something like this together where you create a convert workflow that's named
like Joel's session. Yeah, it just returns a string. Yeah, exactly. And so you could sort of hack this
together, but I like the idea more, more so of having like a front end environment drop down or
whatever that you can select when you, before you submit a request or like, maybe it'll be like on
the send button for, for replay or repeater, it'll have like the send button and then like a little
drop down arrow or whatever, right? Where you click that and you say, send with Joel's environment or
send with Justin's environment. Well, and you think about how this could apply to like sessions,
for example, like that plugin that updates your session in replay. Well, instead you take a request,
you highlight your session and you right click and you say, you know, assigned a variable session or
update variable session. And then all of your requests, instead of having a static cookie,
they're referencing the variable called session. And again, it all updates from one place. So,
you know, you can dynamically update your requests. You don't have to have big long cookies or whatever
in every single request. You just have a reference like session variable and, you know,
Absolutely. That's big, man. That's big. I like that. I would love to see that. I think that one might
take the cake so far. I mean, I think my expido tool, um, like the reason I wrote it,
It's like a good V zero, you know? Yeah. It's a good V zero and it's like solves a,
it scratches an itch that I had in the situation. And it got me, um, a little bit deeper into the,
the Kaido sort of front end plugin environment, which I really liked, but I think there is a lot
of room for improvement there. And I think if you were to use something, if they were to implement
something natively like, um, environments and variables and that sort of thing, then, um,
then that would be massive. And a lot of this would become irrelevant then. Um, yeah. So no,
that's really interesting though. Um, anyway, so regarding that plugin until that, this environment
thing comes out, um, that plugin, I think I'm going to release to the public around Defcon time. So
depending on,
It's already released to critical thinkers, right?
It is, it's already released to the critical thinkers, um, exclusive content channel. So if
you're interested in that, check out, um, check out ctbb.show slash p slash discord. I should probably
actually make slash p slash discord. Yeah. Cause it's like, if you do slash slash discord, then it,
it just takes you right to the discord invite leak. Maybe, maybe I'll make like a ctbb.show
slash ctbb.com slash ctbb.com slash ctbb.com slash ctbb.com slash ctbb.com slash ctbb.com slash ctbb.com
Right. Critical thinkers? No. Ctbb.com
No. Ctbb.com
Ct-ers. There's a whole conversation that was happening in the discord. That's like,
we need a better name for us than Ct-E-R-S. Ct-ers. Yeah. We're all from Connecticut.
Yeah. We're all like C-tier hackers. We're all C-tier hackers. Yeah. Critical thinkers
slash critical thinkers. All right. I'm just going to make that ctbb.show slash critical thinkers. If
you want to get into that environment. All right. Jeez, Joel, come on. All right. You want to take
one or should I take one? Hold on. I'm just reading through. I'm reading through. I'm reading through.
Yeah. So this trace cookies one is really interesting. I don't know if you have more
information than what's written down here, but let me just spin off it for a second. So
I mean, based on what it sounds like, it seems, you know, basically just tracing cookies. Right. So
I find this really interesting when you're trying to figure out like how login flows work and like
what's necessary, what's not necessary. We've talked about this a lot with like cookies and I'm
constantly haunted by whether or not I should be removing my cookies or not because of that one zoom
ATO. I know. I'm like, I'm like, I'm probably just missing an entire category of bug. But that being
said, being able to trace stuff and figure out like what stuff to be looking at, I find this to be a
really interesting category as a whole. And I find myself more and more writing like long filters and
stuff in my in my Kaido to really narrow down what I'm seeing in my proxy so I can focus in on stuff
that matters. Yeah. So like CSS files are really cool, but I don't give a crap about them at all.
You know what I mean? Like maybe, maybe at some point I will care. You know what I mean? But like
most of the time I don't. So, and the one thing about Kaido, super nice is everything's recorded
regardless, right? Like with burp, if you have, I mean, the way that I have it configured is when I
put stuff in like the scope or whatever, it like completely ignores it from the proxy. So if there's
stuff in the past that may have not matched your current scope rules or proxying rules or filters or
whatever, then it's completely gone for good. You will never know. But with Kaido, you can bring that
back. So maybe later if I'm looking for CSS, then I can, you know, find it.
Yeah. The way, the way I used to configure burp as well is like that. And the reason why,
and then I stopped doing that once I got this like server that I'm on right now,
that I'm recording this podcast on right now because, you know, essentially you have to put stuff
that's not in your scope. Don't like, don't record it in burp or else it'll just blow everything up.
And you're just, you're going to be, you know, 30 gigs of Google searches.
Exactly. Exactly. But I think you can afford to not do that in Kaido, which is great.
And it does allow you to have that sort of retrospective. You can go back and say,
ah, you know what, actually I really need to know every S3 bucket that's ever been referenced
by this site. You know, you can do that sort of thing.
Well, really quick. I find the big thing for me is that I will at some point during my hacking,
find a domain that either wasn't in my like search or in my scope properly, or that I didn't know about,
and I'll need to add it later. And all the previous requests I now have, instead of just like being
a completely blank slate and trying to figure out where that's used from then on.
Yeah, I dig that too. But what I was going to say with regards to the trace cookie thing is like,
here's my vision for this. Like, I want to be able to select a cookie and say like,
give me a history of this cookie. And this cookie was like set in this request,
and reset in this request. Like the, like the follow, like trace,
in Wireshark, how you can follow a packet. Yeah. Trace route. Is that kind of what you're
talking? Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no. Trace stream.
You could, yeah. Trace stream, how you can basically like put together a series of TCP packets.
TCP stream. Yeah, that's it. Yeah. Yeah. So like something like that. Is that what you're
doing? Exactly. And it's a little bit tricky because you don't know whether it's being,
you don't have a great way without resending every request with every single permutation of cookie to
determine whether a specific request needed a cookie or not. Right. So it's a little bit tricky
to know what requests exactly needed what cookie. But what I would say is if it,
you could definitely trace the updates, right? Like, yeah, where it's being used is just like,
I mean, generally speaking, if it's being sent in the request, whether or not it's needed,
I think cookies are like so broad as a whole that it's really difficult unless you have like, again,
like a separate, there is that plugin for burp, that minimum request minimizer. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
That does. That basically does that. But I think at least the setting part of like following where
it's being set, where it's being updated, that you could definitely do pretty easily just based on
the server responses and where you have a set cookie header being being returned. Yeah. So I think
creating some sort of mapping, you know, following the lifespan of a cookie would be really interesting.
And then also take looking at a cookie and saying, okay, where, when is this value found in the
response ever? And just kind of tracing those things as well. And then maybe even integrating. So this
kind of goes down to what I was talking about a little bit later in this document, which is,
it would be really great to have something that seamlessly hooks into the front end in both Kaido
and burp and, and, and, and, um, uh, Dom invader sort of does this with, with burp. Uh, but I think
there's, and I'm not a Dom invader master by, by any stretch, but I think there's some, some things to
be improved upon in that arena. And, and I think this could be a really cool one, which is if there is
some way for us to determine whether a document.cookie is being accessed and then parsed, and then this
specific cookie is being utilized by the front end, uh, at a specific page, um, and trace back that
JavaScript execution. That would be also a really valuable piece of this whole, whole like trace
cookie profile that we would build. Um, and, and man, this sort of introspection would just breed the
coolest bugs ever because that's one of the things that's like getting my goat right now is I don't
have enough introspection into when a front end application is looking for a cookie and not
finding it. Um, looking for a cookie, finding it and doing something that I don't know about,
looking for a query parameter and not finding it, you know, and that sort of thing. So I need to do
more Dom hooking to actually understand what's actually happening at the application level.
And I want to create some sort of heads up display either in the browser, just like maybe like,
I'm thinking like a marquee, you know, toolbar across the top of the browser, or like maybe in Kaido
natively or something like that, where it says, um, this page that you're on, uh, looked for these
eight, uh, query parameters. Uh, and we know this because we hooked URL search parameters or something
like that. Right. Uh, that, that, that, uh, tool for parsing out query parameters. Um, so yeah, I guess
that's my rant. I would love more introspection into that. Yeah. Yeah. And I think it's really
interesting. I mean, I think both Kaido and Burp have like, we're out their own like browser
integration type thing where you can launch a browser and it like auto proxies or whatever.
I honestly can, I've had so much trouble like getting behind that just because like, I'm very
used to like, you know, my certain flows or whatever extensions. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. Yeah. So I don't
really like doing that. That being said, one thing that I've done, and I don't know if a lot of people
do this is burp. The only way that I know that you can use Dom invader is if you use the burp built-in
browser, right? But if you look in the way that works, it actually loads, uh, like a dev extension
from like a specific folder. You could do that. I use Chrome, uh, as my testing browser. So I just,
in my profile, I, you know, enabled dev and I load it from the same folder in my own Chrome instance
so that I can continue my testing and I can also use Dom invader still. Um, and it works fine. I think
like half the tool doesn't work properly because it's not like hooked in, but yeah, it's, um,
I, I, I would imagine that Kaido could probably do something similar there or, you know, verb2 where
you could have, um, you know, an extension that you can point your browser to load and that will
interface with your proxy at a more deep level where you could do that type of stuff where you're talking
about like interfacing with the front end and checking for variables and query parameters and
hooking and just wrapping around like all those different types of things. Yeah. Someday, man, I'm really
looking forward to that because I think there's so much, as I start to understand the web environment
a little bit better and I, and I start understanding like, Hey, these individual top level pages have so
much more encapsulated in them than what comes through the HTTP proxy in modern day web apps because
of JavaScript and just how much stuff JavaScript does in so many different spots. And it's not like you can
just look at one spot and be like, this is what it does or this is what it doesn't do. You know, there's
like all sorts of middleware throughout this whole flow. Um, and so tracing that out would be, would be
massive and definitely some, some, uh, some massive challenge. I think that'd be really cool. Um, and, and
while we're on the, on the cookie front, let me just talk about this next one really quick. So I have in the,
in the doc, you're setting cookies that you're not responsible for. So I saw this the other day and I, and it's like a pretty,
it's like an informative thing. Like it's not, it doesn't indicate a vulnerable or anything, but I saw
a, a website, you know, let's call it site.com setting a cookie where the domain was scoped for
like backend.site-dev.com. Right. You know? And it's like, and that was in the domain attribute
for the cookie. And I was like, Hmm, that's a little interesting. Uh, and you know, you hear people
talking about like, look at the CSP headers, like brute force for V hosts, that sort of thing.
And this is another area where you can find internal host names that correlate to your application
that you may be able to use in other areas is, um, if it's setting a cookie that it's not
authoritative for on this specific domain. Yeah. That's super interesting. I wonder if they
just did that for like the ease of developer testing or something so that it works on the
developers laptop as well. It's a bug. I mean, it wasn't an important cookie and, and that was the,
the name of the backend server. And it just like defaulted to whatever it perceived its own host
name to be. Um, so, but yeah, I thought that was, I thought that was really interesting.
That is very interesting. Um, one thing that you, that you put in here, but I also expanded on,
um, highlighting or bolding, uh, basic to foreign coded values. So I think that'd be really neat if it
just automatically sort of showed you that, you know, this thing is a basic for foreign coded.
Um, that's probably a little hard to do accurately. I think, uh, if you just think about like writing
a regex second properly and accurately, or any way of, you know, just generically saying, oh,
this is basically for, as a human, we can like eyeball that so much easier, uh, honestly. Um, but,
uh, that being said, so you can highlight values and it'll try and auto decode it. Um,
in both Kaido and Burp, I'd love to see some expansibility for that, where we could, you know,
write your own decoder, or maybe there's some custom value or encryption that the application's
using and you can just like double click on it and you could, you know, specify that you want
to use your own custom decoder instead. And again, just pipe this through workflows or something. Um,
and, you know, just be able to do some extra easier custom decoding without having to constantly
like right click or pop something up or whatever. Yeah. So, so, because currently in,
in Kaido to do that, you have to select, then right click, go to the convert workflow and click it.
So it's like three, three clicks if you're going through that whole thing.
Well, and you could see how this could also be awesome with like match and replace rules as
well. If you could do that, where you could just do a match and replace rule to call a workflow
and just say like, okay, if this matches, like select this regex and then
that's exactly what I want them to do too, is like convert workflows and match and replace would be
super cool. Um, and then you just define like a regex on the front end and then like a convert
workflow to actually like pipe through it. I think that would be really amazing. So I think that one's
on the, on the unblest as well. But what I kind of wanted to see with the base 64 encoded values was,
um, in burp, there are some extensions that will be like, Hey, this thing is basically foreign coded,
just FYI. Right. And then here's the value. I think that might be even like built into burp by default or
whatever. Um, instead of putting that in my findings tab, I would love for that like base 64 encoded
string to be like underlined or in a different color or like, yeah, where you hover over it,
have some little tool tip or something like that, that draws my attention to it because I'm very rarely
when I use burp going into the findings tab and being like, all right, let me just like check out
what's in the informative section, you know, like, it's always when you're, when you're having some
problem. And then at like three hours later you go and you check in, your answer has been sitting
there and you're like, Oh, exactly. Exactly. I didn't have the certificate and stuff. Exactly. So
I think there's some room for improvement there as far as usability goes, because there are some
detectors, but having it underlined or like having a little tool tip on it would be really good.
Um, yeah. All right. Let's see. I see you wrote GPT integration, but I, this already exists.
I know it exists. They were early on the train. They were, they were. And I, and I think that
there's cool stuff that you can do with assistant, uh, in Kaido. Right. Uh, and I think that's great.
I think there's room for improvement. The reason I say this is because I've recently started using
copilot and copilot is unbelievable. Like absolutely unbelievable, uh, in VS code, right? Where, where you're
trying to write some code and you just like write a comment that says like, write this function that
reverses the string and XORs it. And then, you know, and, and then all of a sudden it just, boom,
it's there. And, and I just, wow. Like how stunning is that? And I think there's lots of ways that we
could integrate this into, um, into Kaido or to burp that would be really like friction reducing. So,
you know, I'm trying to write out this whole syntax. Uh, I can just select the code, you know,
this whole bunch and say, dude, make this modification to it, you know, encode every
slash with, uh, you know, a double URL encoding and just type that out. And then the AI just does it.
Or like, um, one area that I said, and actually, um, we've kind of shouted this out a couple of times.
There's actually a Kaido plugin for this now, um, surrounding actually auto renaming. Yeah.
It's called AI replay, uh, rename by riddle. Um, like renaming your tabs in, in replay in Kaido,
uh, based off of using AI to do that, to make an intuitive name. So like, oh, this is the get
request for this end point, uh, that gets the user information, you know, does that use the built-in,
does it use the assistant like backend that's built in Kaido to do all that? Okay. Yeah.
So there's like a certain number of like token counts you get, uh, if you're a kind of pro user
or whatever. Um, but I just think after using, uh, the copilot and just being able to like select a
bunch of text and then say like fix bug and then just describe what I wanted to change and then have
it do it. I just like, wow, we need this in an HTTP proxy. Yeah. Yeah. And I think the big thing would
be if they could figure out how to make some sort of assistant that is specifically geared towards
that and trained on that type of data. Like one of the reasons that copilot is so good at code is that
it's specifically geared towards writing code. So it's really, really good at that. And like chat GPT
can write code sometimes. Yeah. Depends on what it's doing. Um, but you know, yeah, it's pretty good,
but you know, a lot of the time, well, some of the time it definitely will miss, um, because that's not
really what it's, you know, designed for. Whereas copilot is like trained on, you know,
GitHub and stack overflow data and all that kind of stuff. So it's like very, very specifically
designed to write code. Yeah. Okay. I agree. And I, and I want to say that in addition to that,
I think this is one of the few areas where it's like, I wouldn't really say to the burp team or to
the Kyto team, like, Hey, you should implement this natively. Like, I think this is something that
I would actually pay for as a plugin. Like there's very few plugins that I would like shell out cash
for. I don't know why that is because I'm sure some plugins would make me tons of ROI. Uh, but like,
I don't know, it's just a, now that I'm saying it, it sounds, it sounds dumb, but, uh, but you know,
like you've got JS weasel, right. Which is a, you know, an enterprise product for assessing JS code.
Right. I think definitely, I haven't purchased it yet, but I think very soon when it meets the capabilities
that I'm looking for, that will be a buy. And I think this could also be a buy where it's like,
Oh, there's a really, really, really high quality, um, AI plugin for burp and for Kyto. Um, and this
is a startup and it costs $30 a month if you want to use it or $50 a month or whatever. And it just
reduces friction left and right in your HTTP proxy and allows you to just describe what you want. And it
just does it. You know? Um, I think that, I think that could be a really amazing product.
Super interesting. Maybe you shouldn't have said that on the podcast.
You know, I'm here to add value. I'm here to please take my startup idea and do something with
it. I would love that. All right, man. Um, I got to bounce. Uh, there are a couple more ideas in here.
Maybe I'll be late to this next meeting.
Are there any that you, all right, I'll tell you what, pick your top two. Cause there is one I, I
still wanted to talk about. Um, and, or, so I would pick your top one and I'll talk about this one. So,
um, the one that I'd mentioned, you, you mentioned that, um, uh, I think you said, uh, uh, Hakopiku
was talking about, um, you know, how this, this, uh, this functionality that Gareth had identified is
really good for a lot of stuff. Well, I was thinking like right off the bat, I was like, well,
there should be a OAuth testing plugin. And then I looked through the list and on the list,
it says something for attacking OAuth specifically. And then there's a link to this burp plugin called
OAuth scan that it does exactly this. So yeah, this is another one of those ones that I mentioned that,
is probably just a direct port. I don't know if this one's going to be so easy. It looks like it's
written in Java and it's like pretty in depth. Um, and it does like a lot of different tests and stuff,
but this would be another one of those great ones to port over and get working in Kaido. And
in addition to that, maybe add this functionality, customize it a little bit, like you said, to add in
this additional scan, uh, for this additional, um, you know, a bypass or whatever you want to call it,
that Gareth described this behavior. Yeah, no, I, I, and I think, I think it's great that they have
all these, all these, you know, extensions already in burp. And I think, you know, it's just one of
those scenarios where it's like, wow, there's so many pieces that I don't know about. Right. So many,
so many extension code, you know, pieces of extension code that I don't know how they work.
And I should probably just deep dive in and learn how to use it, uh, efficiently or whatever.
Or I could just write my own. Cause I have to know, I have to have that gut sense anyway, as the hacker.
Yeah. Like this is actually goes, goes to a pretty, a pretty big hacker topic. Cause I've always
wondered like, what makes hackers so scrappy? Like, why don't we just want to pay for something?
Or why don't we want to just use these tools? Why don't we want to reinvent the wheel every time?
And I think the reason for that is because we need to know what is happening at, you know,
at a low level so that we can feed that gut and that intuition of like,
this feels like something I should apply this tool to, you know? Yeah. Um, so I don't know.
I'm sure there's more to suss out there, but, um, okay, let me, let me, let me just, I'm gonna,
I'm gonna do two. I gotta go like, okay, like two minutes, but I'm gonna try to cover two more,
two more extensions really quickly. Okay. One is I would like some extension that allows you to
specify where an API lives and then, um, makes sure that you have 100% coverage of that API. So
let's say I give it a path. I say, okay, all this stuff for, um, you know, Epic games lives under
epic games.com slash API. Right. And essentially I want to see in my HTTP history, if there is a API
endpoint that I'm missing, that I haven't sent to repeater or haven't marked as like boring.
I want that like glowing in my HTTP history, you know? Okay. Yeah. So, so like coverage,
like a reverse target where like in burp, you can have like your target of like things that are under
domains of endpoints that belong to that domain. But instead you say, here's all of the endpoints that
exist and it would say, okay, here's a request for every single one of these and then highlight the
ones that don't have a request. Yeah. Well, absolutely that. But also when a new one comes
through and this is like, you know, one that I haven't sent a replay or haven't marked as boring.
I want that like glowing in my HTTP history. Like, Hey, there's this new one that you haven't seen that,
you know, got bundled in with the other requests that happened when you went to this page.
Yeah. So like marking a, uh, endpoints as like processed or seen basically as well within the scope.
So that when something new comes up that, you know, you can mark them all as seen, but then you can,
yeah. So that I can be sure that I have coverage of all of these API endpoints and I understand
every single freaking thing about this application. Cool. Okay. Cool. And then next one, sorry, last one
is that man, there is, why is there not good note taking in either Kaido or burp? Like how cool would
it be to be able to write notes and like reference, um, tab numbers and like, bro, there's this,
there's this notes, uh, organizer thing or whatever. And burp, I've tried to use it. I can't even tell
you how many times, uh, more than 10, it's never worked. Never. I clicked the button. Nothing happens.
I gave up. Yeah. So it's like, I just feel like this is something that should be super pivotal. And
instead we all have like notes.as, you know, uh, asked if dot txt or whatever, uh, notes dot txt.
And then we all just kind of dump stuff into. Um, but man, it would be really, really helpful to be
able to like apply a note to a specific path regex or like apply a note to a specific, um, request,
uh, or just lots of functionality that should be built out surrounding that. Um, all right, cool.
That's it. I got to run, but notes, please, please somebody build that notes at least notes. Yeah,
exactly. Awesome. Good pod. Cool. All right. Catch you later. And that's a wrap on this episode
of critical thinking. Thanks so much for listening. And if you want more critical thinking content,
head over to ctbb.show slash discord, join the discord. There's lots of great conversations and
chats going on over there. And if you want to support the show, there's the discord subscriber tiers,
which give you access to masterclasses, AMAs, hack alongs, exclusive scripts,
and an exclusive chat channel with us. We'll see you there.